über nacht ungeimpft sowie kevin
klinkhammer ergeht es gerade etwa fünf
millionen deutschen der freiberufliche
berater aus mainz war einfach mit
johnson johnson geimpft bislang galt das
als vollständig seit einer woche jedoch
ist den impfstatus ungültig ich kann
jetzt nicht ohne einen test zu machen
kurzfristig öpnv nutzen das heißt ich
benutze jetzt wieder verstärkt das auto
ich kann nicht ohne weiteres und kaffee
trinken gehen ich kann nicht zum friseur
ja es ist beschränken
kurzfristigkeit weil ich mich eben nicht
planerisch darauf einstellen konnte vor
nicht mal einem jahr wirbt karl
lauterbach noch persönlich für den
johnson and johnson impfstoffen preist
ihnen bei twitter wirkt stark wird gerne
genommen weil nur eine dosis plötzlich
ist all das nichts mehr wert und
klinkhammer muss sich selbst im internet
zusammen recherchieren dass sein
impfstatus erloschen ist am meisten
stört mich tatsächlich die intransparenz
das tatsächlich überrumpeln ohne die
fristen und die mangelnde kommunikation
das löst bei mir durchaus eine gewisse
reaktion aus weil er seine freiheit
beschränkt sieht erweckt klingt kann man
nun eine klage seine anwältin sieht gute
chancen
wir brauchen wir zumindest eine
übergangsfrist die es ja einfach
geimpften ermöglicht sich einerseits
ärztlich beraten zu lassen andererseits
an impftermin wenn sie sich dazu
entscheiden geben zu lassen oder aber
auch rechtliche möglichkeiten zu erwägen
stattdessen sind sie eben von heute auf
morgen ja aus dem gesellschaftlichen
leben ausgeschlossen wie lange gelten
impf und genießen zertifikate eine frage
über die neuerdings das robert- koch-
und das paul ehrlich institut allein
entscheiden dürfen am 14 januar
reduziert das lka auf seiner website die
dauer des genesenen status von sechs
monaten auf 90 tage grund rechtsänderung
mit sofortiger wirkung für millionen per
mausklick durch eine nachgeordnete
behörde
regierungschefs von münchen bis berlin
werden kalt erwischt für uns kam es auch
überraschend es ist nun so ich fand es
auch ein bisschen unglücklich und wenig
nachvollziehbar warum jetzt der
genesenen status gekürzt wird welche
begründungen daran es reicht nicht eine
regeländerung auf seine website zu
schreiben so der saarländische
ministerpräsident
dass in der schweiz der genesenen status
zwölf monate gilt hierzulande aber nur
drei das muss man den menschen erklären
der präsident des robert koch instituts
aber erklärt öffentlich nichts gibt auch
kein interview lässt nur mitteilen das
bundesministerium der gesundheit war
eingebunden es gab keine politische
einflussnahme
eine unangekündigte änderung die viele
betrifft mit wissen von karl lauterbach
und der bundestag bleibt außen vor so
etwas gehört ins parlament wo die
volksvertreter sitzen das kann man nicht
durch eine untergeordnete behörde per
verordnung einfach so machen wenn
menschen weniger antikörper bilden und
deswegen eben kürzere zeit geschützt
sind dann muss das natürlich auch an den
regelungen berücksichtigt werden wichtig
ist aber auch dass es ankündigungen gibt
dass es übergangsfristen gibt vom
bundesgesundheitsminister der eigentlich
gerne und viel kommuniziert dazu tage
lang keinerlei äußerung erst am mittwoch
erklärt karl lauterbach die neue
dreimonatsfrist in einer talkshow weil
wir gesehen haben dass diejenigen die
zum beispiel mit der delta variante
infiziert gewesen sind nach drei monaten
sich schon noch mit der mikro und
effizient können die immunität von
genesenen schwinn der innerhalb
kürzester zeit will das lka nachträglich
mit studien auf seiner website belegen
andere experten sind nicht überzeugt die
infektion ist ja eigentlich die
vollständige immunisierung die dann
lange zeit hält und dieser wahrheit kann
man die nicht entziehen auch mit
einzelnen publikationen die man dann
vielleicht in die eine oder andere
richtung interpretieren möchte
es ist lauterbach sprecher der diese
woche ganz unverblümt auch eine
politische begründung liefert außerdem
können sie diese regelung auch als
anreiz sehen sich impfen zu lassen karl
lauterbach wird wissen dass das nicht
gut kommuniziert und begründet war er
musste intern bereits besserung
versprechen und der druck auf ihn wird
größer